first of all I just want to say thank
you to you guys for making me laugh
um which is always nice uh so uh because
I have some extra time with you guys I
like throwing in some curveballs at the
beginning hopefully you don't find these
too painful
um for both of you if someone is
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why definitely
I'll answer for Jack and I would say
Clifford the Big Red Dog
because I think it I think that it
really exemplifies Jack's ability to
like live in a state of wonder
and to be really present as an actor to
be someone that like understands how to
inspire both adults and children at the
same time it's a rare quality that I
think a lot of actors take themselves
too seriously and they don't know how to
just be like grounded and real but also
live in this wonderful Fantastical World
um so for for Jack that's what I would
say I also think of Clifford as a bit of
a companion piece to robots and really
that there will be you know a fan base
in America that I've maybe managed to
cultivate through Clifford that will be
now coming to Roblox
um and expressing it to be a
continuation of that wonderful family
friendly entertainment and we'll
probably be leaving the cinema within
about five minutes
of shailene's I mean I would probably
say The Secret Life of an American
Teenager is where I would start why not
the American Teenager sorry in England
we called it what I just said
um
uh yeah that's where I would start just
because I think you wanna you'll you
wanna Feast on that and then you can
Devour the rest of her Uber what do you
love about Secret Life I just love the
kind of the the family
Motif I love the design and look of the
show about your character your character
I just thought was the glue that like
held it all together it's such a great
apparent it was such an insight into the
life of a teenager In America which for
me was like because obviously I was a
teenager but never in America and just
understanding what that was like
watching it I found it very informative
it's very funny though because I've been
to London a number of times and I have
friends that live in London and one of
the things I've gone to parties over
there and one of the things when I first
started going over there were people
would always ask me is high school
really like it is in the movies and on
TV because again it's so different over
there yeah we have a very different
approach to I mean they all start
drinking at about 13.
uh Jack this is a question for you um
who is more famous in the United Kingdom
you are your father
um that's a tough one I mean I think I'm
probably still more famous but maybe
he's now more beloved which is if
anything more galling
um and even now in America it's
beginning to happen there's enough
people that I mean I was over there with
him and he got recognized and I didn't
which was a horrendous moment for me uh
and then the the two Americans that had
clocked him then walked past me because
they didn't know who I was I overheard
their conversation and he said uh that's
the man from Travels With My Father and
the other guy was like what's that and
he goes it's a show on Netflix about an
esteemed elderly English gentleman that
travels the world with his youthless son
and I was like
I'm just the doofus son
I have to say that people when they find
like find out that I worked with Jack
they're like did you meet his dad
so depressing and he [__] never stops
now as well I did one show with him and
that's all it was meant to be now he's
cut me loose and he's off doing his own
[__] he's got side hustles Galore like
literally cannot say no to a job he does
a podcast he's on Breakfast Television
every morning like doing the circuit
there promoting this [__] thing he
does reality television the I was
watching The Last of Us the other day
and I'm pretty certain he popped up as
one of the Living Dead in that he is
relentless
a parasite I love it um you both have
millions of followers on Instagram and
I'm curious and I asked this to a lot of
people
um how much do you debate hitting
publish or post right before you do it I
usually post and delete like five
minutes later I'm such a big deleter on
Instagram program
um I I just haven't figured out my
relationship with it yet I don't know
what how we belong together so I'll
think that I understand something and
I'll post it and then I'll realize oh no
that was definitely the wrong thing to
do and it has nothing to do with other
people like liking something or
commenting on something it all has to do
with me self like creating doubt in my
head about I don't know that that was
the appropriate thing to post on
Instagram
I'm a bit trigger happy I think well not
in most in most things I'm I I am quite
good at self-censorship and thinking it
through and I tend not to like get drawn
into anything particularly controversial
on social media to do with like Foreign
Affairs or cultural Wars stuff the only
time that I often let my guard down
there is with sports
normally because I'm drunk when I'm
watching them and get very passionate
and then I'll hit
send on some tweet that will rile up a
load of rival sports fans and then I'll
be getting uh death threats from Angry
Soccer fans for the next week so that's
the only area in which I think I need to
to really kind of like just reevaluate
my relationship with social media
jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys today uh what was it about the
script and story that said oh I want to
do this for me it was it was worth
working with an aunt with the directors
of this movie and also with Jack and
having the opportunity to do a comedy
for the first time that was the most
exciting thing and then the story itself
I loved because it was so a truce and
crazy and and had kind of these
ridiculous
um modalities to it but at the
underneath all of the comedy and
underneath all of the insanity was this
really beautiful message of love and and
connecting to who we are as people that
uh having the elements of of both the
kind of outrageous things with the heart
was something that grabbed me I mean for
me it came along at just the right time
I think I'd done jungle cruise and
Clifford the Big Red Dog
they were great movies and I had a
lovely time doing them but I was
somewhat constrained with you know
improv and how I could sort of express
my comic voice upon them and then robots
came along and it was this outrageous
R-rated take on a romantic comedy and it
was really near the knuckle humor it
came from these two amazing creative
minds and Hines and Casper Christensen
whose work I knew and loved and I read
it and I was like this is exactly what I
need to go and do uh I'll be kind of off
the leash uh to excuse the dog pun and
able to you know go back to what I love
which is you know making really
outrageous uh out there comedy and then
you know the fact that Shailene came on
board to do the movie was just a godsend
because it took what was an exciting
project that could have been like a sort
of fun distraction into something that
was just so much more elevated and you
know she brought everything to the
character of Elaine and E2 and E3 indeed
uh and was the perfect kind of partner
to go on this um like mad adventure with
when you guys were reading the script
and you saw the shooting schedule what
was the day you had circled in terms of
oh this is going to be like a tough day
or for a day that you're like I cannot
wait to shoot this definitely the E3 day
for me I was so excited to do that scene
mostly because we didn't really rehearse
it so we kind of had no idea what it was
going to be until the day before I think
we we were at that location and we kind
of sketched it out a little bit
but that scene was it was complicated
there was three different versions of me
and there was only me and one body
double and so trying to play all of
those
um characters and map out what it was
gonna look like while also keeping the
humor in there it was just it was just
fun and uh I was excited to do something
ridiculous and wild I would say I was
definitely very aware of that scene
being on the horizon
part of the shoot in my head it was more
going to play out like a game of erotic
twister and what it turned out as was
something I would say closer to a UFC
about
red hand mark on my ass as well when I
watched the premiere of the movie and
then was informed afterwards that that
had been CGI added to my buttock that's
not a good job isn't it some point your
ass was red like I it was I kept asking
huh it was red and it was added in post
there was some it was it was tomato red
in real life as well the camera just
might not have picked it up
um
I think that I did not expect to talk
about uh the color of your ass
well it had to have actually been a lot
of fun or I mean very challenging to
play multiple versions of a character
and on the same day because that has to
get in your head yeah it was it was fun
and challenging
um I think I think the most challenging
part for me was just making sure that I
had all of the dialogue correct for both
of them because it you're when you're
memorizing the scene you're memorizing
all parts of that scene and being able
to jump from one to the other uh
making sure that you have the alignment
of who that character is correct
um that was a little bit tricky also
because we didn't have a lot of down
time so as soon as we got one shot we'd
have to just change clothes and jump
right into the other but other than that
it was just it was really enjoyable yeah
I I loved it as well because I sort of
feel like
in everything that I do I either play
one of those two types of parts I think
I only have like two modes either
complete [__] or naive milk toast and
in this I sort of got to do both
sometimes in the same scene so it was
quite nice to be able to bring both of
my
um to like character options to the same
movie and and get to to kind of play in
both of those worlds so yeah I enjoyed
it one of the things about this is It's
you know it's like talking eight nine
years in the future and what's funny is
uh people are really gonna do this
what's in this movie at some point you
know it's it's uh I always find it
interesting because uh um I don't think
as a population we see movies and then
we learn from anything you know like I
look at Jurassic Park and I think the
people that are involved with cloning
they've never seen the movie or believe
that they'll never be the ones who do
this yeah and I mean it's so strange how
much more well not strange I guess it
was inevitable but you know we Shot the
movie two years ago and then even in the
time since then
we've been on you know our group chat
sending each other all of these links to
these stories that feel so relevant
um and Tesla announcing their you know
move into Ai and and then all of these
like the latest news cycle which again
it's like uh feels like it's a very
pertinent time for this uh movie and
story to be told so whilst it was the
case when we read the script I mean it
was written you know
four or five years ago I think and the
original story that it was based on was
from you know 30 years ago and uh I
think yeah it's it's really it's really
interesting time for it to be coming out
into the world and wondering whether
yeah as you say like people are going to
watch this and we go you'll be going oh
my God like it's it's terrifying that
this is nearly a reality or probably
just you know using it as disposable
income and entertainment and then uh
within a couple of years this will be
our reality oh it's on the horizon
um so I definitely want to ask you guys
filming the the specifically the dancing
and how much did you think about what
you were gonna do before you know what I
mean because you haven't you have a
choreographed thing and Jay you're
wearing heels of course because uh
movies like to put women in heels when
they're doing dances and large action
set pieces yeah we I mean we committed
to that dance sequence we had a
choreographer who we practiced with in
his dance studio
as well as under the Albuquerque Heat
um
it was it was a lot of fun but we I I
definitely kept messing up Jack I think
you were on it more than I was trying to
get our steps like in line was a little
bit tricky in your head as well you
think you look amazing when you're doing
that
you nailed all of the moves and you're
like when I watch that back it's gonna
be like unbelievable it'll be like a
scene from you know Dancing with the
Stars but and then you see it and you're
like oh it's it's incredibly
underwhelming I mean very funny
um
it was underwhelming but in my head we'd
absolutely nailed it and people were
going to be like oh yeah these robots
look like they're professionals
um which was the intention but uh they
had to make a slight pivot I think in
the editing uh Suite
um but yeah we had to learn to dance and
then I also had to learn to ice skate
which was something that I again like
really committed to and did for months
before the shoot started I went to this
ice rink down the road from where I live
in London and went and had all of these
ice skating lessons
um and yeah that was a bit it was also
totally unnecessary because they only
shot me from the the waist up so I
didn't need to be able to ice skate
really and uh also it just meant that
anyone that saw me at the ice skating
rink in London just assumed that I was
training for this show that we have in
England called dancing it's quite a lot
of low rent celebrities take part in
every year literally every time I walked
off the ice again
if the rider strike continues you will
be on Dancing with us no I won't ruin it
out I won't rule it out
um listen I already got a wrap with you
guys but I'm just going to say I am
really looking forward to the after
party season two I have screeners I just
haven't watched yet and Shay I saw clips
from uh um dumb money at cinemacon and
it looks it looks so good awesome
I've seen more than I have
for that one yeah uh on that note I wish
you guys nothing but the best I'm sure
I'll talk to you guys for future things
in the near future uh and congrats on
this movie I I really enjoyed it and I
laughed a lot last night
thank you thank you have a great day
good to see you nice to see you have a
great day